informations principales de cette fin de
journée bien Vladimir Poutine qui s'est
adressé à l'armée ukrainienne il leur
demande de prendre le pouvoir à Kiev et
donc de renverser le président volody
mers elanski on l'écoute
je répète aux forces armées ukrainiennes
prenez le pouvoir
il sera plus facile de nous entendre
avec vous plutôt qu'avec la bande de
néo-nazi et de toxicoman qui a pris en
otage tout le peuple craignant
et Bruno darrou est avec nous Bruno là
c'est un appel à faire un coup d'état
quoi ah oui c'est un appel d'un chef
d'État qui est encore chef d'État
étranger quand même qui s'appelle donc
l'armée ukrainienne à faire un coup
d'état se débarrasser du pouvoir civil
et nos démocratiquement élu
démocratiquement élu et notamment de
volodières zenenski donc ça peut
paraître aussi un peu paradoxal puisque
un des objectifs affichés de l'invasion
russe en Ukraine c'est de démilitariser
l'armée ukrainienne donc déjà la
première journée a été marquée par le
fait que l'aviation
ukrainienne a été totalement démantelé
ces bases aériennes pilonnées par
l'aviation russe donc d'un côté il
demande aux militaire ukrainien de
rendre leurs armements et d'un autre
côté leur propose un rôle politique
bon surtout ça lui permet en fait de de
montrer que il considère toujours que
les civils qui sont au pouvoir acquiesv
sont un peu des civils dégénérées
drogués nazi et qu'il faut donc s'en
débarrasser sa visiblement c'est un
objectif très important et d'ailleurs
c'est quand même une des questions
importantes dans les heures qui viennent
la sécurité du président zellenski de sa
famille on sait que la France a proposé
son aide pour éventuellement l'exfiltrer
mais pour le moment selon les dernières
informations il serait toujours acquiesf
mais clairement on voit que pour
Vladimir Poutine en fait mettre en place
un régime militarisé ce serait mieux il
est plutôt l'habitude de traiter avec
avec ces gens-là tout ce qui est de la
sécurité lui-même est issu d'un organe
de sécurité enfin le KGB qui était aussi
un organe de renseignement mais c'est un
peu le logiciel de Vladimir Poutine
l'armée les forces de sécurité les
forces de renseignement vous avez ça
dans un pays le pays est tenu puisque ce
qui est peut-être pas complètement faux
enfin on voit que ce serait son scénario
un peu idéal pour être sûr que l'Ukraine
devienne devienne un état satellisé à la
botte de Moscou dirigé par des
militaires finalement c'est il fait ce
qu'il fait en Russie le fait en Ukraine
là il Bayonne un opposant oui enfin
c'est même pire il est en affinité aussi
oui enfin officiellement en Russie il y
a quand même des institutions un
gouvernement un parlement où il n'y a
pas que des militaires enfin alors après
on sait que dans l'appareil
d'État russe effectivement l'armée les
forces de sécurité les services de
renseignement jouent un rôle très
important pour opérer un système de
surveillance et d'encadrement très serré
de la population civile ça oui mais là
ce serait presque pire parce que ce
serait maître au pouvoir une jante il y
a quand même pas une jeune qui est au
pouvoir à Moscou mais donc voilà en tout
cas on voit que c'est que cet objectif
reste important pour lui et qu'il
préférerait aussi faire faire le sale
boulot aux militaire ukrainien plutôt
qu'à ses propres soldats alors ça veut
peut-être dire en fait tout ça ce sont
vraiment des des conjectures que la
progression des soldats russes vers Kiev
et peut-être plus compliqué que ce qu'il
attendait et que donc il joue sur les
divisions peut-être au sein de de
l'armée ukrainienne pour convaincre les
éléments les plus pro russes de
s'emparer du pouvoir et en même temps il
accepte l'organisation de négociation
après ce qu'a dit volody mers éléments
ski qu'il était prêt à discuter de la
neutralité de l'Ukraine donc vis-à-vis
de l'OTAN oui mais si on comprend bien
enfin s'il y a une logique
à comprendre ce que veut vraiment
Vladimir Poutine en même temps faut
toujours écouter ce qu'il dit et lire ce
qu'il écrit parce que en fait il est
quand même aussi d'une autre manière
assez constant donc en fait si on
comprend bien il aimerait que les
militaires prennent le pouvoir acquiesce
et ensuite ces militaires envers une
délégation à mince pour la discuter
entre gens sérieux convenables non
drogué donc des négociations sans Hélène
ski quoi voilà sans Hélène ski
il veut absolument écarter les civils
pro occidentaux en tout cas du pouvoir
il veut renverser le pouvoir actuel de
toute façon quand il avait expliqué ces
deux objectifs
des militariser l'armée quand même
c'était un des deux objectifs et puis
des nazifié voilà ça c'était l'objectif
politique et donc tout ça quand même il
y a une constance seulement il change un
peu les moyens il essaye peut-être qu'il
trouve que ça ne va pas assez vite
peut-être s'attendait-il à ce que Kiev
tombe plus vite et que on aille
s'emparer de de sellensky parce que il y
a quand même le risque le
présidentielens qui soit soit fait
prisonnier soit emmener à Moscou et soit
jugé pour crime de génocide puisqu'il
dit que l'armée ukrainienne commettait
un génocide dans le don-basse par
exemple donc il y a quand même crainte
la visiblement il dit bon en gros le
premier qui s'empare de zenenski c'est
très bien et si les militaires
Ukrainiens veulent veulent se charger de
ça je n'y vois pas d'inconvénients on va
vous montrer l'image en direct de la
Place Maidan il est 16h38 ici à Paris
une heure de plus à Kiev et cette place
qui est un haut lieu de la Révolution
orange il y a eu beaucoup de
manifestations
elle est vide elle est vide et les chars
que les Ukrainiens redoutent ne sont
toujours pas arrivés ils ne sont pas
arrivés mais le symbole de la victoire
voilà pour Vladimir
la place en fait bon enfin qui sont
Amaidan à Kiev la doux est parti la
fameuse révolution qui pourrait devenir
Poutine est un coup d'État il faut
monter par les Occidentaux et notamment
les États-Unis là c'est la c'est pour
lui c'est la revanche totale il faut
bien voir que le dossier ukrainien pour
le lion pout c'est une obsession depuis
très longtemps donc là s'il arrive à
installer les chars russes Amaidan à
Kiev pour lui c'est la victoire après
l'autre signe de la victoire ce serait
donc la chute du pouvoir pro-occidental
dégénéré qui est en place selon lui qui
est parlons peut-être de volodières ski
et lui en 2019 largement élu il
promettait de mettre un terme en tout
cas de résoudre la guerre dans le combat
aussi de mettre un terme à la corruption
d'abord est-ce qu'il y a eu des réformes
qui ont été réalisées sous sa présidence
alors il y a il a lancé des opérations
contre la corruption évidemment c'est
compliqué parce que bon l'Ukraine tout
n'est pas blanc noir l'Ukraine aussi
avait sa son histoire de de d'oligarques
corrompu qui voilà les plus corrompus
étaient en général les plus proches de
la Russie il a quand même lancé des
opérations pour essayer de réduire la
corruption sur le dossier des accords de
Minsk en toute objectivité
il estimait quand même que ces accords
étaient défavorables à l'Ukraine donc
c'est vrai qu'il ne s'est pas pressé
pour mettre en application les accords
de Minsk notamment la réforme de la
Constitution ukrainienne notamment le
fait que le don de base devait acquérir
un statut spécial alors il ne faisait
pas ça en disant moi je peux pas mettre
ça en application tant que les groupes
séparatistes prorus n'ont pas déposé les
armes ce qui était aussi prévu par les
accords de Minsk et chacun se renvoyer
la balle les Français et les Allemands
tentant péniblement de faire avancer les
choses avec le succès que l'on sait
puisque aujourd'hui les accords de mins
que sont morts et enterrés j'aimerais
vous écouter sur les sanctions
économiques Bruno les 27 ont adopté le
deuxième train de mesure hier qui vise
les technologies fondamentales russes
l'accès au marché de capitaux l'énergie
et l'aviation on a entendu aussi Alex le
bourdon nous dire que finalement les 27
vise directement servir la broche et
Vladimir Poutine est-ce que ça c'est une
première et c'est très symbolique
surtout c'est il y a eu une évolution et
sans doute beaucoup beaucoup de
négociation entre hier soir et là il y a
une heure une heure et demie quand ça a
été annoncé parce que hier soir il y a
beaucoup de personnes qui disaient que
c'était très mou il y avait beaucoup de
personnes oui qui disait que c'était mou
mais surtout au sein des dirigeants
européens certains dont le chancelier
Olaf scholls disaient non non les
sanctions contre Vladimir Poutine et
voir on parlait peut-être pas
spécifiquement de Serguey lavrof mais en
tout cas qu'on trouve Vladimir Poutine
non c'est bon là on a fait notre paquet
de sanctions on s'arrête là et
visiblement certains pays sont revenus à
la charge pour dire il faut qu'on envoie
un message plus fort il faut qu'il y ait
aussi une forte portée symbolique et du
coup ça ça a produit ce qui a donc été
annoncé là en début d'après-midi le fait
que symboliquement évidemment c'est très
fort la personne même de Vladimir
Poutine et visée par les sanctions en
tout cas le gel de ses avoirs financiers
ainsi que ceux de Sergueï lavrof qui est
pour des millions de personnes à travers
le monde le visage à l'extérieur de la
Russie depuis des années parce que c'est
donc le à faire étrangères de Vladimir
Poutine donc gel des avoir financiers
c'est quand même fort je crois que c'est
la première fois qu'un une des premières
fois qu'un chef d'État en exercice est
visé par des sanctions comme ça après
toute la difficulté c'est de récupérer
les avoir financiers de Vladimir Poutine
qui est nécessaire un des hommes les
plus riches du monde selon le magazine
Forbes dans la fortune serait estimée à
200 milliards de dollars ou d'euros je
ne sais plus mais enfin bon vu les
montants ça fait pas une énorme
différence après toute la difficulté
c'est de les récupérer parce que
évidemment une bonne partie de de cette
somme qui correspond quand même à peu
près à 7 8% du PIB français pour
remettre un peu les choses en
perspective
et bien une bonne partie de ces avoir et
évidemment cacher dans des dans des
situations offshore des sociétés
offshore donc il faut évidemment
retrouver la trace et puis il y a des
procédures il y a quand même nous sommes
quand même dans des états de droit donc
on gèle pas comme ça d'avoir financiers
d'une d'un individu comme ça donc ce
sera compliqué ça prendra du temps mais
le symbole quand même est bienvenu ça
veut dire que il y a pas que les
oligarques autour de Vladimir Poutine
qui sont visées long vise le principal
responsable de la crise qu'on connaît
une dernière question sur Joe Biden qui
a annoncé qu'il nommait la juge
afro-américaine qui est engie Brown
Jackson à la Cour suprême première femme
noire on a le sentiment que il y a une
un peu une différence que la vie
continue à Washington bon et que la
guerre la guerre voilà continue en
Europe oui alors c'est à dire que en
fait
là pour le coup la géographie joue quand
même c'est à dire que pour pour nous les
Européens évidemment est un conflit qui
n'est pas à nos portes enfin qui est
quand même sur notre continent qui a je
sais pas 3 4000 km de chez nous donc
c'est quelque chose de très concret de
territorialement très présent ce n'est
pas le cas évidemment pour les
États-Unis Joe Biden a aussi annoncé
hier des sanctions mais il a refusé
comme d'autres en Europe un peu l'arme
nucléaire pour le moment de ses
sanctions qui seraient le fait d'exclure
la Russie du système Swift mais c'est
vrai que dans ces allocutions Joe Biden
parle toujours aussi du fait qu'il faut
pas que ça pénalise les consommateurs
américains il reste quand même très
focalisé comme souvent les présidents
américains mais disons que là c'est bien
prononcé sur le bien-être des citoyens
américains il faut pas ouh là là que ça
vous savez les embêter dans leur dans
leurs habitudes de consommation et
effectivement pendant ce temps la vie
continue Joe Biden peut-être estime-t-il
qu'il a qu'il a fait le job en quelque
sorte qu'il a fait ce qu'il fallait et
que maintenant bon on va bien voir on va
bien voir ce qui se passe mais après de
toute façon le fond du problème c'est
que les sanctions même si beaucoup plus
forte plus massive ça n'empêchera sans
doute pas Vladimir Poutine d'aller au
bout de son aventure puisque le problème
quand même fondamental c'est que comme
il n'y a aucune option militaire qui est
envisagée par les Américains les
Européens et donc l'OTAN à l'Ukraine est
seul pour se battre après peut-être
certains réfléchissent-ils à la
meilleure manière peut-être de d'aider
d'armée de financer la résistance
ukrainienne s'il y en a une là c'est
c'est en train de se jouer maintenant
c'est maintenant qu'on va voir on est on
est qu'au deuxième jour après tout de
cette offensive bon notamment l'arrivée
dans les grands centres urbains c'est là
qu'on va voir s'il y a une résistance de
la part de l'armée ukrainienne
apparemment les combats se
poursuivraient autour de Tchernobyl et
puis évidemment aussi de la part des
civils Ukrainiens une dernière
information le Conseil de l'Europe vient
de suspendre la Russie suite à cette
invasion de l'Ukraine voilà c'est sans
surprise merci Bruno Darroux